okay
so
maybe like two months ago
i made a video saying that i
did not think that fans actually wanted
a new splinter cell and i have reason
for saying that and i stand by it
but like two days after i made that
video
uh the rumor came out or the leak i
suppose
that uh ubisoft is working on a new
splinter cell game
today or yesterday
uh they actually released a developer
presentation called splinter cell remake
stepping out of the shadows
i'm very excited to watch this um
the news breakdown which i have already
gleaned from it being all over my
twitter timeline is that this is a
splinter cell remake says it in headline
as well
um which i'm much more on board with
very curious to see how they tackle this
what i had said previously was that i
don't think with the way that ubisoft
currently makes games that they would
even really be able to make
the kind of splinter cell that splinter
cell fans want my argument is that i
think that they would they would make
something open world um they would make
something multiplayer they would make
something that is more in line with
every other game that they make and and
i think that's almost a requirement for
ubisoft considering uh their games very
much share systems that's how they're
able to make so many games which with
such big studios is is the sharing of
those systems um
and i also
don't
generally think that that stealth games
are always seen as especially marketable
from uh big studios um
a remake however
is
pretty literal we'll see what they're
going to do but i'm way more on board
with a remake i do want that that is
super exciting and what's interesting if
i've learned anything about remakes um
this is specifically from talking to
mike bithell on my video game podcast
here called player watch listen
uh it would be that
he believes uh as a game director um
that if there is a remake announced then
it usually
leads to
a new game uh because it's a very good
way to test the waters and test the
market and i think that that is a very
good test for stealth games for ubisoft
who otherwise would not necessarily want
to take a risk and instead tends to
favor making like stealth light games so
without further discussion
let's
watch the presentation and see
what this is going to be i'm excited
splintercell is back ubisoft toronto has
begun work on a remake of sam fisher's
most classic opera
and with the series return on the
horizon it's the perfect time to look
back at the game that started it all
who do you work for splinter cell
launched back in 2002 a time when
ubisoft was best known as the company
that made rayman a bright wild
platformer splinter cell was not that
good a cell was so good a dark and
serious stealth action game that favored
slow methodical movements over frantic
action
no one was quite sure how fans would
react i don't remember it looking like
this
to find out more about the development
of that first game and the lasting
effects it had we spoke to some of the
folks that helped launch the original
splinter cell and some that are helping
to bring it back
i can't tell if this is original footage
of remake footage but i'm guessing this
is original footage very first time we
really understood that we had a hit in
our hands is i guess when we were
talking to microsoft like we had that
feeling that good feeling but it wasn't
validated by anything and we never had a
hit before actually like not a big one
like oh that's wild microsoft came to us
and looked at it
they knew also something was up and they
were considering it for their e3
showcase at the time for showing off the
xbox
and it was super scary for us because
we're like how are people going to react
we don't know because it's very dark is
it going to come through nicely on the
screen is it going to show off its
colors
the feedback
from e3 was so incredible so it just
gave us uh give us a huge push to uh to
get things done and get this thing on
the people who are actually stationed
probably from the [ __ ] e3 and for our
competitors and for
um you know for for players at large it
probably came out of not a game it was
this whole
who is ubisoft it was
a transformation of what ubisoft could
do
and how they were regarded that was very
special because at that time then
assassin's creed they used to make some
wildly different games we were producing
games but we were not in a in a triple a
mindset at that time and this game
became somehow uh a great inspiration
from the themes it was that lead into
being uh
did really
i loved child of light and valiant i
wish they'd make some games like that's
popularity as well this this has been an
incredible trigger
for the whole studio to reach for this
level of achievement for other games but
what exactly was it that drew in
audiences at that e3 what did splinter
cell do that set it apart from the crowd
i don't remember i was very young it was
pretty black and white light shadow
it's instantly relatable and instantly
something that you know how to play with
people paid attention because they have
never seen
such amazing visuals at first that whole
shadow and light was beautiful and it
was giving a dimension that they had
never played with and it had to do with
i wouldn't have considered the ability
of the xbox to render that they were
focusing these dynamic lights with
dynamic shadows and dynamic real-time
shadows and um cool and it was really
the ambition of the team
uh early on to to push the
the visual fidelity of the game
as far as we could the way art and level
design had to work together
um to deal with you know
how dynamic lights would affect the
gameplay as well as the visuals was
probably one of the biggest challenges
of development so i feel like i should
pause this one
i feel like we are probably not going to
get a look at the new game right now but
i am very interested in
everything they're saying right now so
i'm going to continue to watch the rest
of this video anyway game came on just
really
had a brilliant presentation
that was so critical for the actual
design itself so you can only imagine
how exciting that would have been for
the team the first time we saw the you
know the fish tanks that you could you
know you could shoot the fish tanks and
the water would lower down with the
the stream and down to the level of the
bullet hole and that would stop and you
know you could keep shooting it and
lowering it little tweaks like that
little little surprises that that you
know people just found the time and the
energy to put in to add the polish and
the care to the game uh that was great i
remember thinking to myself i wonder if
that was like
the tech advances that were part of that
game the stencil shadow creator movie
clock i wonder if that's like an
advantage of not seeing your studios aaa
is that you can take that extra time for
polish for a third party studio
because obviously first parties don't
look at things that way um
maybe for a third party aaa like
maybe that you know that that pressure
that stockholder pressure you can't get
that anymore i don't know
all of this stuff and i just remember
thinking to myself you know um how that
was even possible at the time visually
it was amazing you know the
light effects were remarkable ahead of
anything else that was being done at the
time
but it was even more than that
the use and exploitation of light and
shadows set splinter cell apart from its
competition we haven't thought about it
take more than that to deliver on the
development team's promise
a promise they felt so strongly about
they put it right on the box art stealth
action redefined was
born out of the fact that this was it
was this was a challenge to
the god of tactical espionage action
which was uh metal gear solid it
was really the mission that splint cell
set out for itself it was okay if we're
going to take espionage if we're going
to take stealth action how are we going
to position that
in a way that
fits the tom clancy brand values as well
we had
rainbow six redstone was working on
ghost recon
those were obvious on plenty games but
splinter cell came from montreal
and montreal wasn't working on tom
clancy at the time
and when we looked at it we looked at
the fantasy we looked at
the realism and the techno thriller
aspect of it so different to rayman
tom clancy back then there was a lot of
you know
a lot of games that were very kind of
heavy on just shoot kill be done that's
how you get through these
situations um made you slow down and
made you think it made you ever being
very people understand the threats that
were ahead of you and it layered all of
those features together
and it rewarded players for thinking
differently for for being a bit more
kind of patient with you know the way
that they chose to to solve those
situations the idea that we want to
replay thief like the first three thief
games who can go into those places that
no one's
supposed to be able to go to and do what
no one's supposed to be able to do
that's an incredibly powerful fantasy
and it's a lot of fun to be that person
we used an actor that was a recognized
person that was new at the time anybody
have a line back to third action
what the hell is going on they can still
use just declared
now it's something that a lot of people
do a lot of game publishers it's kind of
normal but at the time it wasn't and we
really looked at it like first it was a
clancy brand so we looked at it like
something bigger than just a video game
marketed it that way and created a
persona sam's a great character he's
iconic um he's smart he's funny he's
fast he does what he can do
with a minimum of waist he's uh high
speed low drag
and he's just an incredible fundraiser
what's the great way to describe the
star of the splinter cell franchise
let's be honest he'd get nowhere without
his signature night vision goggles
that's true not only are they an
essential tool in sam's arsenal they're
the symbol of the entire franchise those
three green dots and that iconic sound
yup that sound is enough to know exactly
what game you're dealing with that's a
by splenice and i think that uh we
didn't realize how important i feel like
that's useless it was until someone said
you know we really got to have a much
more iconic sound in here somewhere and
it had this kind of very military uh
you know just because of the speed at
which technology moves it kind of became
its own thing in
in time and it adhered to sort of the
genuineness of it and and kind of stuck
19 years ago splinter cell put ubisoft
on the map and changed the landscape for
stealth action games across the industry
now thanks to the upcoming remake a
brand new generation can experience the
best splinter cell has to offer
for future updates on the splinter cell
remake follow this channel and visit us
at news.uesoft.com
that totally was yusuf shout out to
yusuf everybody
um so yes obviously not an update seems
like we will be getting consistent
updates
that's really cool i love stuff like
that especially when it's like the
people who worked on a game 19 years ago
talking about like parts of the
development i i love that i could listen
to that kind of stuff forever i try to
do more of that um
on my channel where i can for sure
definitely no news no glimpse of it uh
but that leads me to think that we will
see something pretty soon
so
yeah just gonna have to keep keep
holding out keep waiting i am actually
very excited about it we'll see um what
they have planned for sure
um
but i look forward to replaying sponacel
it's been a long time so sign me up
let's go
and then i will also see what they
inevitably turn into a new splinter cell
hey maybe it will be everything we hoped
for
that would be awesome